all right amanda hello world
amanda how are you darling good it's
another day in sobriety and recovery
how long has it been now um seven and a
half months
seven and a half months you've been here
right seven and a half months of my
sentencing but i think it's like
a year now almost a year because you
were a little over two months
in in jail right you've been clean
for you think how long i've been clean
for like
probably 11 or 10 months yeah i think
you're right um yeah
and you you've the last time i
interviewed you which was when you were
at the other rehab and
yeah i was craving real bad no more
cravings so
i got it's a blessing so when did the
cravings fade away for you
when i got here today yeah so
so the cravings have faded no more
cravings listen to you you're
more anxiety you're more clear-headed
yeah i'm more clear-headed
my mindset has changed about drugs and
everything so
i feel really great about my next step
and
just coming here it's been a blessing
good for you
yeah it's hard to believe i think i'm
talking to a different entirely
different person you are i mean
no more schizophrenia no more crack no
more
in the streets you know i'm a completely
different person
rehab has done me well yeah no you've
done great and you've never
tried to escape you never you know yeah
no escaping
yeah get out of control and you'll be
out of here
in a few months right i'm supposed to be
going to
sober living in vegas that's connected
um it's a sober living so i should be
going there by the end of april
if if everything goes through right
yeah so i have a little freedom like on
the weekends or whatever and you seem
really happy
yeah i'm happy the second i see you
you're smiling yeah
yeah you're cheery and talkative and
everything yeah i'm so glad you hooked
us up with lima she feels like a mom
you know i never had my mom so it feels
like such a blessing just to have her in
my life and
just have you guys for support because i
really only have my dad so
you couldn't pick somebody better than
lima yeah she's great liam's great
yeah yeah lima came out of nowhere and
just kind of
made this all happen didn't she
definitely she made a lot of things
happen
a lot of things and uh
looking back at your days on skid row
how do you see that now
my days on skid row i just see it as a
learning experience
um i'm
i want people to see that it just takes
time and effort
being sober and being in recovery are
two different things i just want to put
that out there and i'm in recovery i'm
i'm here to make action and do the
things that i can do to stay sober for
the rest of my life
good for you yeah it's hard to believe
you're speaking like like
yeah i'm an adult how do you know you're
20 years
i'm 25 25 yeah and what are your plans
when you get out of
um i'm supposed to have a job lined up
with lima but most importantly i want to
become a cna
i helped out with my autistic brother
growing up so that's something i think i
would be really good at and
and i would enjoy it that's great yeah
good for you i have a hard time looking
at you and
visualize imagining you were the same
person yeah
that was crazy i watched the videos on
skid row
it's just like
schizophrenia is a true demon if you
have schizophrenia you gotta stop using
so that you can see
your true diagnosis and your true mental
illness because they can't diagnose you
if you're on drugs so
you have to get off drugs first and once
i got off drugs the schizophrenia just
went away so it was drug induced
schizophrenia so you see your problem
as yes you were addicted to crack but
you were also schizophrenic from the
crack
right it was from the crack once i
stopped smoking crack it
it went away yeah cause i've seen other
people down on skid row that that were
fairly normal and then all of a sudden
they just became like you were
yeah out of their minds and it wasn't
just the drugs they were using i think
it's schizophrenia or something like
that i mean i was tripping
and the things that i accused my dad of
in those videos is not true
i had schizophrenia i had a mental
illness where things i hear
voices hallucinations all that so my dad
has done nothing to hurt me he's a great
guy he's always been there for me
and i really love him i just want to put
that out there
i mean i can attest to that i mean you
used to say everybody was a child
molester
yeah i would just edit those out but
they didn't leave that way from watching
steve wilkos
and mari and all that stuff yeah yeah
excited about your dad that one time and
i left it in because i didn't know who
you were or your dad and you were just
some little
street urchin that came into my studio
with her right there's no bra
no shirt no shirt no nothing
no shoes i was tripping i watch those
videos all the time it's crazy
it's crazy how do you feel about about
seeing yourself like that
um sometimes it makes me cry and
sometimes i'm happy
because normally when people come up to
you and tell me they've seen my video
they see how great i'm doing so it's
kind of like a confidence boost like
yeah i'm doing it
yeah you are yeah i think you're going
to become like the the example of
how to beat these really tough
addictions yeah
because without the without the jail
time so
so you i think assaulted your dad and
your dad called me that one night and
said what do i do amanda just assaulted
me the police are here
and i said i told your dad like just put
her in jail she's going to walk the
streets barefoot and
and probably get killed eventually so
putting her in jail for a month or two
isn't gonna
hurt her so that's you went to jail and
then from jail you went
the court decided that you needed to do
rehab for one year right and if you if
you didn't do one year of rehab then you
went to prison for five years
and that wasn't my motivation to stay in
recovery
honestly my motivation was just those
videos of me on skid row it was never
oh i'm here maybe the first couple
months it was
but then after a while watching the
videos and learning about recovery
that's something that i'm really
interested in
and it's doable that's what people have
to understand being sober
is doable you can do it yeah i think the
way you did it
the combination of forced jail
for a couple months and then forced
rehab for another year almost
that basically meant a year of and
that's the problem with these rehabs
they're kicking people out only 30 days
30 days look who you were 30 days for
real i would have been out there doing
the same thing
and and worse you know what i'm saying
so these rehabs really have to be more
sensitive to
insurance and all that and just know
that 30 days is not enough
90 days might not be enough but it just
depends on the person but
definitely two weeks is just that's just
not okay
to kick somebody out after two weeks and
that's happened
i've seen that happen like a lot and you
turned the corner after about
six months it seemed right right like
three or four months in
i wanted it for myself yeah yeah yeah so
and then there was also some probably
some psych meds you were taking
and things like that they were right
right the meds really helped too and
helping my mood and my cravings and i
think the last time we did an interview
with you you were still a little
groggy yeah yeah and today you're very
clear-headed
yeah wow it's an amazing story amanda
definitely i'm i'm i'm blessed to have
you and lima you guys are the best like
honestly
well all i can say is lima is an amazing
woman
she is because when she asked me who
would i recommend
for my channel she wanted to do
something for my channel she would do
this for
and i recommended you know like you know
maybe
five or ten people yeah they would all
have been good candidates but i said or
you can choose the hardest of all
right which was you man i never thought
of rehab out there and never even
thought of the word i was just so in my
mental illness that
i couldn't see it and that's why things
like al-anon and stuff like that is
important for
the family to get involved so that they
can understand addiction it's not about
policing them
it's not about cutting them off it's
about being there for them
and being there every step of the way
because relapse
is a part of the stages of change and
addiction so they're noticing that so
you just got to stay there and be there
for your family um
remember i hope the whole recovery world
learns a lot from this
from your story yeah definitely because
i think there's some really great
lessons to learn here because
like like i think 100 of the people just
said you're
you're an impossible case right and look
at you now yeah
amazing story yep and your dad must be
so happy right yeah my dad we talk three
times a day
i mean he's just such a great guy i mean
i can't wait to leave here we're
probably going to travel around
the world together that's just being
sarcastic but we're probably going to do
a lot of fun things together because
he's like my best friend now we talk
like three times a day so yeah
yeah amazing amazing
and do you think there's any chance that
you'll ever
go back to that kind of life um
there's always a chance honestly that's
what they teach us here in rehab but
it's a great answer um no i don't i
don't i don't want it
i don't like the feeling and i don't
know why i was doing it if it was making
me feel paranoid like that and just like
it was just crazy yeah it's almost like
it's a trap yeah running out of cars
running at hotels
it was a schizophrenia honestly but i
don't want to blame it on the
schizophrenia it was me
but it it was a schizophrenia
yeah but the crack kind of induced it
right right yeah
exactly and there's a lot of people down
on skid row just like that that seem out
of their minds but it's it's the
the drugs whether it's you have to get
off the drugs first and then go to the
doctor
so that they can give you the right
diagnosis that'll never happen in a
month or so
yeah it's gonna take several months
right right it's gonna it takes time
that's why these rehabs gotta stop
kicking people out after two and three
weeks and four weeks i'd be mad because
it's like
that's not okay that's not enough time
does your dad come to visit you here has
he been here to visit you no oh you've
got to see this place
yeah it's very nice here yeah next time
maybe he'll get to come see me when i go
yeah yeah yeah maybe or if we come out
again like this
yeah before you leave he'll come with us
yeah that'll be cool
yeah i miss my dad i love him so much
he's my rock
honestly yeah he supported you by
himself right right
no we had a little help from my mom's
side of the family but they were really
immensely
they they mentally abused me a lot so
it was good having my dad come there
every day
because i see my mom and me so they had
a little problem with that so
yeah that's a rare father you've got
yeah
we've been through a lot together yeah
he was very patient with you while you
were
you were doing some questions yeah he
could have pressed charges on me way
back when there was one time where you
disappeared for a week or two
you were down with south central i heard
somebody saw you down there
right i was on every cat corner in la
i've been to
i've been in every california in l.a and
that's a fact
amanda i'm so proud of you thank you
mark
can't wait to see where your life goes
from here yeah me too
it's a beautiful story thank you thank
you man bye guys
you